hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Fran bow now I played the
demo for this game a long time ago and
it really impressed me because it was a
point-and-click style adventure horror
game that had really surreal bizarre and
grotesque environments and a lot of
really weird things that were going on
and it really impressed me in the demo
and I'd been waiting for it forever
everything's fine it feels like heaven
doesn't look like heaven I see my
parents they look so happy they have a
present for me
I wonder it's a cat so sweet and pretty
dark is the deepest night it's mister
midnight my best friend my only friend
we're having dinner and I see Aunt Grace
- I really like her a lot it's Friday my
parents are going out on grace takes
good care of me we are having so much
fun it's Monday night I'm playing with
mr. midnight but something feels real
bad oh I a strange creature outside my
window
I don't like it it scares me suddenly I
hear something it's mom screaming I want
to know what's wrong
a bright light shines from my parents
room I go closer
and closer mom dad please don't
mommy daddy
all righty then I can't quite rule Fran
please follow my voice on the count of
three you will wake up one two hey there
we are okay three hello hi doc Fran how
do you feel I feel terrible considering
everything that I just saw I feel like
dying probably be okay I feel like dying
I don't understand why you make me do
this
try to calm down this is part of your
recovery my parents are dead recovery
don't you get it and my parents are dead
oh poor thing everything will get better
I promise better then let me go that
would be better you should not tell me
how to do my job
well maybe you should do your job a
little better but now I have something
for you friend oh really I said to give
a little sass on this one see the desk
there's a little package for you
it's from Aunt Grace take it okay cool
this was my mother's purse what's inside
your mother's purse open it there's
something inside examine dearest Fran
here's the purse you like so much I
thought you would like to have it when I
was thinking about you I remembered that
you like to examine objects and combine
them with other things so I hope you'll
always keep this person give it and all
the other things you find a good use
never forget the creativity is
absolutely the greatest gift you have
loved on grace she is worried about you
see I'm worried too because I'm not
crazy and still here stop it you are out
of control young lady can I leave now
can I go to my room please yes you can
leave but before you do it is time for
your medicine I don't want to try more
medicine it's called duo teen and it
will make you feel very relaxed nurse
we're ready
oh hey nurse has given
trusty very much anything new today dr.
dear nothing actually same visions as
before oh I see here Fran take a
medicine
I don't do women's voices very well I
tend to give them all very very deep
voices oh boy I remember this from the
demo I don't feel good oh no take her
back to a room and nurse don't let her
take this ever again yeah she kind of
had a bad experience from that but I get
a feeling that I need to take a lot more
of that medicines as the game progresses
now I remember a lot of this from the
demo but they did change around a few
things
beware Fran bow if you leave the house
of madness I will hunt you down catch
you and bring you back to insanity
that's so sad Fran wake up oh the poor
little kitty wants to help the medicine
will help you escape I'll be waiting for
you in the forest Thank You mr. midnight
but why weren't you oh I love you as mr.
midnight gonna secretly be the evil
entity that's haunting my life mm-hmm
chapter one my sober day see if there's
a lot of interesting things about this
game besides the grotesque misc of what
the environments showing what the that
what happens to Fran bow that is all
fantastic about the game - I love that
it's so like it makes you not well I
have to get out of here okay I must have
missed the first one something about
getting out but I like I love this game
because when I played the demo it was so
interesting and interactive I mean I've
played a lot of point-and-click before
but this one took it to a different
level because I don't know if I compared
to Alice in Wonderland yet but I wanted
to because it kind of had that feel of
going down the rabbit hole and exploring
an entire and
in a world filled with madness where not
everyone is mad in there the patient was
found near the Oswald asylums showing
signs of psychosis the bow dagger
family tragedy details omitted treatment
dr. Marcel Dean has tried different
medications and all have been cancelled
because of side effects
psycho what I'm not that for sure and
only 10 years old Nora diagnosed with
psychosis locked good reason to get
curious I will get your nose I was gonna
be playful are you a happy clown can you
make me laugh I'm having a hard time
laughing again I will get you nose oh
that's so kind of sad hopefully this
won't fall on my head while I'm sleeping
well that almost guarantees that's gonna
happen
I love out like everything is just
grotesque it's awesome red and tiny you
are hiding from me oh you want the
medicine I hate the monster I have to
find mr. midnight I have to find him now
I miss my kitty he hides because he is
afraid he told me that the medicine
would show me where he is that leads me
to think that you know I will find you
mr. midnight oh boy don't be afraid my
dear kitty everything will be just fine
that makes me think more and more that
it's not good for you and that actually
mr. midnight might be a bad influence
oh holy moly something fell a handy hook
I'll save him to play pirate later
probably not oh sweet sweet melody I saw
I kind of forgot that the character even
though I just read that she was 10 years
old I kind of forgot that she is just a
10 year old girl wandering through this
weird place my legs are just fine that
empty bottle empty glass is nothing
useful towels towels I don't need towels
let's see hello hi oh I want to know
what she's writing I'm curious I guess
the nurse would let him never let me
touch anything excuse me sorry Oh Fran
you're awake good how long was I asleep
three days maybe was that the medicine
that made me sleepy yes it was the
medicine that's why you're not taking it
anymore
lady nurse I did something see you are
nothing but trouble what is it hmm
broke the curtains I was trying to look
outside and I accidentally broke the
curtains accidentally I have to fix this
follow me I'm sorry I didn't mean to I
don't feel like following you though see
I better go and talk to her oh okay
alright then hello
something is missing have you seen the
hook that holds the curtains seeing
nothing no miss I haven't seen anything
well I have to go and find something to
fix this you little girl
okay thank you I can feel the love
pouring out from your cold stony heart
alright fine then ooh whoa that is cool
I also like the art style it's very
simplistic but also it leads or it lends
itself to the atmosphere that is trying
to create tower-defense or is it defense
tower I guess I that is my way up okay
so now that she left I should be able to
find something on her desk would it get
here I'll keep these patches to stop
blood because I plan on bleeding a whole
lot later violent trauma can have a
great impact on children totally
changing their normal lives for example
children damaged by trauma can have mild
the severe deficits and some abilities
such as trusting people near them seeing
the world as a safe place making
decisions etc because of these effects
some traumas can lead to several
symptoms of major mental illness for
example not trusting other people are
not feeling safe in the world this can
be interpreted as paranoia okay traumas
traumas traumas the word doctors love to
say
hehehe that brain looks like a turtle
dang Puri is this a child is sad the
patient has been sleeping almost all the
time she only wakes up to drink water
but I don't think she remembers that
after drinking she goes back to sleep
again
she hasn't been social for three days
either some kids have come around and
asked about her and when she would come
out and play okay
justine 8'h is that a clue for something
okay that his handwriting is awful no
doubt okay pills pills hide oh I know
what that is okay whoa why is there gun
there seriously why is there a gun there
all right good all right so eight eight
so this is just saying that the numbers
are the codes so I can open up that if I
just assign the numbers to the thing
okay examine it what pills are inside I
know it I have to crack the code okay so
hey CD obesity done done okay the pills
Kitty told me these would help me
alright cool then do I have an unlimited
supply and do I actually want to take
him is the question yep yes I do holy
crap you got a little blood on your
mouth are you okay oh my god oh my god
that's so weird
get out creepy creature what are you huh
tell me okay
empty bottle empty glass alright hello
miss nurse how are you doing
okay excuse me lady nurse this may be
very useful oh man but I love it so much
that love how grotesque it is it's so
cool
I just wondering if these show any
different view well they do whoa there's
a handprint ah the playground good night
trees and moon I'm pretty sure the
playground isn't a good escape route I
like the bunny swing thing it makes me
feel dizzy oh that is so weird okay let
me try just this mirror or this window
here and then I'll move on oh I'm not so
easy to see through this good okay so
now I can carry on oh my god how's it
going there oh that's my head oh is that
my head get me my head back please good
god this is so weird oh this is so weird
oh man I I adore this is so cool oh
you're sleeping sweet bunny only wake up
oh that's sad what happened to the clown
where'd the clown go I hope he's not
around here oh god no it looks like he
escaped from the bay that's not good I
don't want to meet the clown okay what
does the say now who did it that's the
good question who did it it was not me
now there seems to be a way down oh hi -
happiness Oh - happy it's full our
secret box
hey I'm the one who she's around here I
don't know it meet any of the dark
voices to shush me why are you looking
at me like that you terrify me what is
that black thing sitting next to you you
can see the patient came to Oswald
Asylum with his mother
the boys developed paranoid behavior
paranoid not yet diagnosed Oh wouldn't
mr. horse are you having a good time
I'm not having the best time the world
oh your head I'll try to put your head
back on oh well I'm sorry I can't help
you mister dear I tried my best okay so
that one's locked so there's bound to be
something down here like the extent of
the demo that I played kind of had some
elements of what we're seeing here but
not all no absolutely not you can't tell
her that but she has to know you can't
keep her away from me
the reason is more than clear grace no
it's not I've want to take her home now
you can't Fran's mental condition is not
appropriate yet I'm guessing that's Aunt
Grace I have no idea what happened to me
oh hi why am I here now was that real oh
dear Aunt Grace I wonder what she has to
tell me the doctor has no soul I'm going
home tonight alright then what does this
Fox say foxy Fox don't cry no use my
hand as a tissue would you like a hug oh
god that's so sad that's so weird
alright let's see what we can do I was
that doll there before I don't know
see I used to have a blue dress like
yours I can't play with you now I'm in a
very secret mission okay so maybe I can
use one of the items that I have if I
combine combine the knitting loom
knitting needle with the little box it
won't do okay-
okay alright then never mind I'm gonna
use this try to use it on that almost
but there's another hole I need
something else okay so the hook combined
with this little box oh it's open okay
Oh oh cool I have a key
I didn't know that I could just that
easily get a key Oh was this drawer
locked was that the thing I think I'm
room yeah okay so this key must go to
this yeah there's something inside oh
bobby pin oh god that's so disturbing
I'm not okay with that I am NOT okay
with that
alright let's carry on so now that we
have the bobby pin we should be able to
do something with it combine it with
this yeah there we go okay so you use
this on the door and apparently a
ten-year-old can pick locks let's go
Fran wait okay I snapped out of it hello
are you leaving tonight yeah maybe I
will if you help me I will if you help
me the only thing I know is that the
office is the key the key is there a key
inside the office I saw the doctor write
a secret code a secret code to open the
yellow door he doesn't want me to tell
you who
who him you mean the blow all doors are
closed you are prisoner of my games and
nobody will help you escape okay cool
that's interesting leave me alone I hate
you all that's so sad
mommy daddy I need you so much right now
no I won't let that monster snobby you
go girl
you show them who's boss you show that
nurse who's boss
you know what's going on okay I think
this is just about the extent of the
demo but things are still radically
different than what the demo actually
was portraying the maze we never get to
play there
whoa tonight the fog is pretty thick how
can you tell it's barely crossed the
horizon okay wish I could get lost in
there so there's another door open here
hi you look fun another clown oh boy
hello you see them you do right what see
what the creatures that follow everyone
the shadows you mean the shadows uh-huh
I can't see them but I know they're
there see I wish I didn't see them you
like to draw I love to draw let me just
change the subject on everything I love
it too but tell me more about the
shadows crayon a crayon I want to find a
crayon I draw all the time you have
crayons right next to you little girl I
wanted what are you drawing something
that's very helpful thank you what is it
my dreams go now okay
fine then if you could try to find
something else around there a real
flowers they smell so sweet the patient
was a victim of sexual abuse by an
unknown person which almost killed her
this event created auditory
hallucinations and thought disorder
office
so horrible oh this is one of those mute
clowns how do you know it's a mute clown
how can you even tell I mean a mine okay
oh let me see red puppet and a serpent a
Teddy and many other things okay so what
about these crayons here that's mine my
crayons can I have it I just like this
green crayon so much can I have it no it
won't be able to grow a green then
that's ridiculous I can't give it to you
but you have so many come on yes many
colors but you know they don't like me
drawing wait well why do you draw so
much who who does who the nurses they
tie me up and what I want to draw I
can't
the nurses are crazy when I can't draw I
hurt myself
then comes the red milk look no no oh
God so horrible oh man please cure me
yes and stop the red milk I'll see what
I can do whoa let's take a pop a pill
why do you look like a fabric doll oh
god it's so horrible
tiny tiny hands all over you eating your
soul that's a rather dark thing to say
what the clown go I don't know maybe
somewhere even the purest things die in
this place I think I found the clown go
on maybe if I touch it he will jump and
scare me a lot more right nothing
happened it must be dead Oh what was
that
oh no daddy was not there mommy would
not care
that's weird as hell could God
hello this wasn't blocked up before okay
hi you're my beloved friend okay if you
want to hug me try to catch me if you
can't catch me it's because you haven't
found me murder okay oh this is weird
okay the King likes drawing who's the
king Oh alrighty then somebody wrote
something here interesting what this
wasn't here before
you damn right it wasn't so did the
pills just wear off after a while or do
they do I have to actually like sit here
for a while or do I actually have to
take another or something oh man
okay so I gotta make the pill we're off
I think and that way I'll be able to go
down the staircase that was there before
guys so horrific alright so let me try
oh oh
okay so all I do is I closed the pill
bottle and that does that oh hey there
you are you should be in your room the
door was closed but you left it open I'm
sure it was not open I know because I
locked it how did I get out then it was
open old lady don't try to trick me
Oh charge of room would wait for the
doctor okay I think I looked at
everything I needed to I don't have time
for this you need to find my way out oh
I thought oh oh okay all right I get it
so there's another piece of the puzzle
oh hey how's it going never mind did you
break out free middle room that's not a
nice friend but I'm hungry sir I haven't
eaten in days I won't listen to any of
your excuses young lady no food for the
rest of your life see mister doctor
please just let me go out and eat
something you have to learn how to
listen to those in charge of course sir
lesson learnt just don't do it again
Fran don't we need now then get back to
bed thanks doctor this is almost abuse
but I love you or something whatever you
want to hear
go screw yourself alright we'll see if I
can get done with cafeteria this
actually let me see what's in this first
still spoopy the throne is empty I
didn't realize that anyone could see me
poofy gross oh this is the only one
hello hi sir Oswald Harrison a bearded
old man the skate is very locked I
wonder what that blinking light is for
that signs show where things are in the
hospital the reception room you always
find a nurse in there okay hello sir
how's it going I'll get with you in just
a second hey you turned off the office
door let's see
Annie Shultz Daniel Gosselin phil was
here today phil was here today that
seems to be the only thing that she
cares about phil was here who's Filmore
Bronston then hi sir how you doing sir
the key hanging up there can I have it
here if I could give you the key if you
could give me Oh God
now God what a bastard you can kiss your
butt that is really weird
I can't reach those tiny windows okay
then if I call emergency I don't think
they would help me this table isn't
interesting at all fine I'll go get
something to eat then hello hi hello are
you all right
what is that supposed to mean I wanted
to know I just wanted to know if you
feel okay I don't want to tell the
doctor will cut your head open if you
don't leave he likes to eat brains he
already took mine he ate all my thoughts
create your brain he will eat yours too
I saw you inside the doctors office you
were dead Oh No if I have to go I hope
you find new thoughts oh boy okay a
little weird but not the weirdest thing
and I've seen so far hello Isabelle
would you like to help me escape
good night shiny toys elephant sir you
are very pink and soft clowns on the
walls in the house of madness
your tiny hat is but sometimes she says
things that are actually quite profound
and interesting and then other times
very much not what are you doing kid
I've no idea what you're doing
hello what are you doing it doesn't work
the papers not working
what do you mean the paper should be
working like they told me what does the
paper do I need the paper to show me
what's on the television RC but why
isn't it working the waves must be
powerful
Jesus channel please okay I'll try my
best
clickety-click how about that one OOP
boink human testing approved oh good
how about that one that one seems like a
fun one it works it works a miracle
thank you paper vision positive grade
can I see no this mine if you want you
can take the papers that didn't work I
suppose I can use it oh thank you for
your Grace's help I'm busy paper vision
revision in action okay thank you a
little paper boat take me to the sea and
beyond the action men could either of
you help me find my kitty I don't know I
imagine when I take this pill it's not
gonna help very much
pink sash is now mine let me examine
this while I'm not on the pill well that
looks borderline nice
oh no they did it all wrong they get you
ready two little visas please take me
out of here please take me out of here
oh my god that's so weird
oh I see that I see that oh you can't
fool me
oh that is so creepy
okay let's see you look at me I say I
care while you're dying of hunger and
thirst
what hello how's it going Isabel wake up
Isabel the black shadow is touching you
it says that you're going to die soon
are you afraid of death I hope not
because it may happen even if you don't
like it I will laugh at you why I will
lie to you I will hide you inside the
shadows Oh No Teddy what are you doing
here
do you want your way to meet another
teddy I don't think so say hello from me
when you get there oh oh so dark and
creepy so dark and creepy
oh no the lady nurse died I wonder who
did this it wasn't me the grandfather
clock is big and grand on that big what
have we here chocolate mmm yummy I don't
like the bitter coffee many of the days
pasta it's weird
mommy loved to paint roses I don't like
this painting it feels like mr. Oswalt
is staring mr. midnight are you here
they hired you because they love you I
don't know what that means they harm you
because they hate you a little boy
everyone feels ashamed of you is that
the shadow speaking to me or is mi mi
she is speaking to the shadow there
oh hi how's it going they are dead
birdie-bird and like you the holy man
took all your clothes off oh how pretty
all the roses are right your mommy
doesn't believe you oh god please tell
me if you can hear me why do you have
this creature next to you he's staring
at you maybe he wants to eat you oh god
it's so gross this door is always locked
at night I can't go out and play let's
let's oh okay everything's back to
normal now goody goody gumdrops and he
loves to drink the milk like a kitten
don't touch my sward okay I didn't know
was yours you should bow and speak
clearly to me I'm your king I bow to you
sir
very well my child what is the purpose
of your visit
I want your cane Sarah what walking cane
do you mean my sword
yes your highness your sward what would
you give me in exchange
anything you need your highness maybe a
crayon because the King likes to drink
bring me a castle and a horse only then
when I grant you my sward but don't you
like to draw maybe you'd like to draw I
thought you were hungry okay
then there has to be another way around
first let me see if I can look out the
windows first and he clues this is the
playground okay so if I carry on over
here oh hey everyone's here hello hello
are you new here I haven't seen you
before no are you from downstairs uh-huh
they think I'm better now what's your
name could you please kill me whoa okay
that's a bit of a Donoho I have to go
bye bye bye bye bye now hello hey Annie
how are you
aren't you afraid of me not particularly
why because I can do magical tricks and
make you sleepy I didn't know you could
magic tricks show me show you but it's
very scary it's better if you do it I
can't I'm not a magician I can give you
the magical stuff really whoa
yes the magical stuff that will make
anyone fall asleep that's amazing
powerful and grand here is a gift take
it slowly oh okay how does it work
I'm guessing I sprinkle in this in
someone's food and they go to sleep
magical fairy dust and all that
okay bye Annie stop looking so
permanently shocked all the time okay so
that's all the time that I have for this
episode I hope you guys are enjoying
this is so intriguing like just the
level of detail in the story I know it
it like is a point-and-click adventure
so that kind of leads itself to what the
thing that it is but it's just so
interesting to see so let me know what
you think of this game down in the
comments below let me know if you're
enjoying it and thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video